you
hello and welcome from the karolinska
institute in stockholm sweden where
we've just discovered who has received
the 2000 a prize for physiology or
medicine with me to discuss the prize is
Professor yarn answer a member of the
medicine prize committee professor Anson
thank you very much for agreeing to what
to associate nasty announcements made
could we begin by you telling us whose
receive the 2009 nobel prize for
physiology or medicine so we have three
laureates harm sir house and receive the
award because his discovery of human
papillomaviruses cause of cervical
cancer while frances marie sinha see and
lick montigny received the award because
of the discovery of human
immunodeficiency virus and this this is
a place that was divided between two
subject areas which is unusual for the
medicine prize and something I'd like to
discuss later but if we sort of turned
to be depriving individual price
separately could we discuss the hair
upon thousands or housings discovery the
cervical cancer viruses gives us more
about the discoveries that involved in
this process so that was the price given
to hypothesis that was generated and
took 10 years to elucidate whether it
was right or wrong and he formed the
hypothesis that human papillomavirus
consists of a whole family of virus and
indeed there were specific types that
cause cervical cancer he proved that to
be true and he identified a completely
new set of types of papillomavirus than
associated with malignancy that is now
contracting at least 500,000 individuals
per year globally and you mentioned that
at the very beginning of the
announcement that this was discoveries
that were talking about breaking this
was something it wasn't generally
accepted by the scientific community
could you elaborate on that please at
the time when he made the hypothesis the
scientific community thought that the
cancer was caused by human herpes
simplex type tool virus the virus that
was known to cause genital ulcers but
never have been associated with
malignancies in humans though there were
evidence
animal experimental model that that
fires actually could cause cancer and so
how did professor saw house and go about
breaking this Dogma how do you make
people convinced that this virus was
indeed involved with cervical cancer the
long journey he had to take was to make
new diagnostic methods for being able to
detect HPV DNA within the nuclei of the
cells and for that took a long time and
also to realize that was so many
different types so he had to make so
many different type of reactions in
order to prove the case and what key
breakthroughs it was his continuously
work on clinical samples to have a
complete conviction that he was right
when the first five years he never found
a single positive example from any
cervical cancer he still consisted with
his belief that there were some types of
HPV that actually were causing this and
piece by piece he put it all together
from cervical genital wart over to the
cervical cancer and had to do that he
made small pieces of DNA that he used as
well crow bands for fishing for
complementary DNA from the clinical
samples and he did it with a technique
that is called low strain stringency
hybridization so that partial binding of
the DNA was enough for his fishing
experiments and then he refined the
tools all the time until finally came to
two reagents that worked out for and so
he looked for DNA within normal patient
cells that that were originated from
human papillomavirus yes and you have to
remember that at that time point you
could not capture this virus and also
the tumors didn't produce viral
particles in the tumors the viral genes
were incorporated into the host genome
and thus he could only detect them part
of the virus and those jeans that were
incorporated in the cancer cells
and there were two particular types of
this virus that were the key
breakthrough could you tell us a bit
more about that please yep and that
tells you a little bit how much he was
able to fish out so he started by
discovering the HPV type 124 then came
the 5 & 6 11 was the one that caught him
on track to detect HPV 16 and 18 which
was the two types that was associated
with cervical cancer seventy percent of
all cervical cancer are caused by HPV 16
or 18 and those were the ones he
discovered and how did they cause cancer
human papilloma virus is original for
causing skin warts but how does this
other virus that causes that's or
disease cause cancer we were able to
demonstrate that in the malignant cells
were two specific set of viral genes
that were overexpressed e6 and e7 those
make the chromosomes in stable so that
they can mutate in addition they
generate uncontrolled growth of these
cells so that they can turn into a
malignant state and that was the key
experiments to demonstrate how the virus
was associated with them with the
cervical cancers and one stupid time
scale does that involved i mean this
won't be an instant thing or virus
inserting its own DNA into cells and
cells unbecoming tumors what actually
happens so in most individuals in fact
ninety percent of those that actually
get infected they will spontaneously
heal this infection within two years
time but in some it becomes a chronic
infection it generates what we call
viral latency no virus is produced but
incorporation instead and totally
something around point eight percent of
all infected with the high risk types
are at risk for developing cancer so
what do these discoveries allow us to do
what was understanding that human
papillomavirus 16 and 18 will cause the
majority of cervical cancers there are
two major effects by that one is that we
now have improved the screening
technology
Papanikolaou smears has been used for
more than 40 years the addition of now
screen for high-risk human papilloma
types allow you for much more secure
risk evaluation and then advice for
medical treatment for those that have
the chronic infection with these
high-risk types the other development is
that we now have generated vaccines
against HPV 16 and 18 they mount
neutralizing antibodies to this virus
ten times better than the actual
infection so it's better than nature and
it has been already been proven that the
vaccine protects against acquisition of
the virus however we will have to wait
at least 10 to 15 years before we really
are sure that it also with effect in
acquisition of cervical cancer so with
these discoveries vaccines have been
development can hopefully prevent the
disease which is quite quite prevalent
worldwide could you say something about
how prevalent in this place I mean the
the cancer occurs in five hundred
thousand individuals per year in
addition these viruses also cause other
type of cancer cancers of the anus of
the penis and over tonsils and those
vaccines can have effect there too
you